suburban high school this time near Los
Angeles is closed this morning while
students and police look for anything
anything that might explain America's
latest deadly school shooting a string
of gunshots caused chaos yesterday at
Saugus high school just as the day was
getting started a 14-year old boy and a
16 year old girl were killed three
others were wounded the suspect is a
tenth grader Nathaniel burr how his 16th
birthday was yesterday he's now in
critical condition with a self-inflicted
gunshot wound our lead national
correspondent David Beck know is at
Saugus High School in Santa Clarita
that's just north of LA David good
morning why did this happen how did this
happen where does the investigation
stand the sheriff says the gunman acted
alone but they really have no motive to
explain why he would have ever done this
in the first place the sheriff says the
suspect used a handgun and at the scene
they found a magazine which was empty
the sheriff says every bullet was used
on a student except the last one that
the gunman used on himself the lead
detective in this case says he watched
video from inside the school that shows
everything which happened and from the
moment the student pulled the handgun
out of his backpack started shooting and
then shot himself it took just 16
seconds
[Music]
last night there were tears hugs and raw
emotion as this community comes to grips
with the horror that happened hours
earlier two teenage victims were killed
on the campus of their own high school
by one of their own classmates how are
you feeling um still feeling like
confused Julianne sandy knows a freshman
at the school he told me he saw the
shooter from just fifty feet away and he
took off running hours later when we met
him he was still trying to make sense of
the senseless I want to know why he
didn't like what was the reason for that
was the police call at 7:30 8 a.m. the
school day was just beginning and
off-duty officers whose relatives are
students at the school were some of the
first on the scene student backpacks
littered the site where the shots rang
out panicked teens dropped everything
and took off running in every direction
we all raced out and then while we were
racing out we heard three more gunshots
behind us and it's just the scariest
part is that you don't know where
they're coming from inside the school
teachers heard the shots and they
reacted quickly securing the doors and
building barricades using their desks
it's not people running outside our
window
and so we all we locked the door and we
hid ourselves behind the teacher's desk
she was shot in her side here and she
was actually shot again in her shoulder
as well choir teacher Kaitlin Holt was
inside the school
she helped one of the injured students
by dressing and bandaging a gunshot
wound there's just nothing that I as a
teacher if you've been following this
story you may have heard the Sheriff's
Department say yesterday that there was
an Instagram account
with a post that said Saugus have fun at
school tomorrow and the Sheriff's
Department said that account belonged to
the gunman while Instagram has
reportedly said it does not belong to
the gunman and they have disabled that
account for violating the company's
policies listen every town which is a
gun control advocacy group it says what
happened here at Saugus high school
yesterday was the 85th incident of gun
violence at a school this year Anthony
all right David thank you